أنا متحمس جدًا لتقديم Apple TV 4k ،
فهو يدعم معيار الصناعة HDR 10
بالإضافة إلى Dolby Vision أفضل
تجربة HDR وقد أعدنا تصميم
واجهة مستخدم Apple TV بالكامل بدقة 4k التي
نقدمها للرياضات الحية حتى
لا تفوتك  ستتلقى
إشعارات عندما توشك إحدى الألعاب على
البدء
أو إذا كانت هناك لعبة قريبة حتى تتمكن من
بدء المشاهدة على الفور ، لقد
عملنا مع استوديوهات هوليوود الكبيرة
لجلب جميع عناوين أفلام 4K و HDR الخاصة بهم
إلى iTunes لنفس الشيء  السعر مثل
HD إذا اشتريت أحد هذه الأفلام
بدقة عالية من iTunes ، فسنقوم
بترقيتها تلقائيًا إلى 4K HD بدون
رسوم إضافية ، يبدأ Apple TV 4k الجديد
من 179 دولارًا ، وينضم إلى الفيلم الحالي الذي
يمكنك طلبه بدءًا من 15 سبتمبر.
Apple watch series 3
تحتوي على هاتف خلوي مدمج ، يمكنك تلقي
مكالمة مهمة هي ساعتك فقط
والرقم هو نفس الأرقام الخاصة بجهاز
iPhone الذي لا تحتاج إليه لإدارة
رقم منفصل وتطبيقات الطرف الثالث
مثل WeChat تعمل عليها  الخلوية  حسنًا ،
يمكنك بث 40 مليون أغنية على
معصمك ، لدينا نسختان من السلسلة
3 ، أحدهما به خلوي في 399
وإصدار بدون خلوي يحتوي على جميع
الميزات الرائعة الأخرى في 329 فقط
وسنحتفظ بالسلسلة 1 في السطر عند
يبدأ سعر جديد من 249